come on
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
whatever
[Music]
you're right
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
are you ready
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
what's going on guys I'm pretty sure
everyone can hear me fine can you hear
me King
yes sir okay everything seems to be
working fine currently I I can't promise
you everything's gonna work fine you
know how it is King things will go just
fine until it's actually time to do
stuff and then my mic stops working my
headset stops working it's it's it's a
real travesty man it's a real travesty
so we we are at another episode of r r
with the Lords of me and King you know
we got a lot of stuff to talk about
today uh you know I've been slowly
working on the production value when it
comes to the to the channel you know we
we got some uh stuff to go over
all right so first off I think when it
comes down to it can we probably
we should start with the attack on Titan
stuff man you know start with the
homework what do you think
sound
um
it might be
yeah
going like a [ __ ]
oh sorry all right talk now
hello
this is on that extend guys it is it is
uh you know we we have a new
thing going on I think you should be
fine now you should be fine now because
I don't want in the chat if I'm still
like I'm trying to make things simple
you know I'm trying to make things
simple he said King sounds like The
Wizard of Oz yeah okay yes like he still
sounds like The Wizard of Oz or yes we
good because I need a clarification
there's a difference better attic levels
are better
all good
all right I can't trust the uh the the
the realm today you said it's better
they said it's better conflicted stuff
let me no Echo Echoes over well let me
see how I sound on here
he said I'm good now
yeah I sound fine
all right it is what it is all right so
let's get into it man you know so what
what which the the homework last week
was King you know he knew uh he
continues his Attack on Titan grind and
we both go watch Megan we are going to
watch uh talk about Megan today so uh
don't worry about that we got a lot to
say about that individual film you know
King is so extra about this show he
wouldn't even talk to me until the show
because I was trying to like get a
little bit of how he felt about the
movie he's like you're gonna have to
wait for the show man you got to get
those raw reactions I was not trying to
share anything about that uh movie so um
but Attack on Titan
I told you dudes I was gonna figure it
out
the giants eat the little people
and poop them out and they become Giants
so
I was sitting there trying to figure out
I'm like where all these Giants coming
from they're eating these people but why
are they eating these people and what's
going on with these people and then my
boy Aaron got eight
I was like I was really basically
through with the series Beyond should
you I was just like
the main dude that I'm watching it for
just got killed I don't need to watch
this no more I don't care about nobody
else like that
and then
a wild skinny Titan showed up and he was
busting butt fighting other Titans I'm
like oh what's going on and then
they opened it up and he come out of old
boy neck excuse me
and it's Aaron and I know it because I
kind of felt it I felt it that that
Titan was going crazy
all right so they they get him out of
the neck another thing that I I observed
somebody
knows about killing them in the neck
because that's where the people reside
somebody knows the truth
and they they not talking the truth
they're not telling the truth something
is going on in the background something
shady is going down and somebody's not
telling the truth because it's very
weird that you fighting these big Titans
they are impossibly fast they're always
hungry and they always kill them who had
to be the the balls to say you know what
I'm gonna hit him in the neck who said
that so they must know something
somebody knows something that's setting
up these people to do this anyway
Aaron had performance issues the next uh
uh
video
so you talk hold on just to clarify
you're talking about the part where he's
like like trying to to go on with on
will right well what what happened is
they they they get him out they bring
them over to the to to the club to the
peoples and then
um
everybody's looking at him funny because
he's like part Titan and they looking at
him like we don't trust them
y'all was just running behind this dude
he was just your leader a second ago so
now you don't trust him and he saved
your behinds so um uh Armin and and his
little girlfriend which she likes to say
we're family anyway uh
is protecting him and they shot a rocket
yo these dude I mean a cannon
oh boy uh uh the captain flipped out
shot a cannon at him and he partially
turned into a Titan BY biting his hand
which is when he inflicts pain on
himself he turns into a Titan which is
some strange stuff that I'm seeing in
here so you know he didn't fully turn he
partially turned and then um you know he
like he he kind of blocked it and these
dudes are setting it up again to get
another Cannon shot out and you know
they just got out of there
until the real boss showed up and calmed
down everything because boy with the
wild eyes was trying to just mess
everything up for everybody so welcome
back to Aaron I I don't think that's
fair because you got to look at from
like their perspective they never seen
something like that and these Titans
have been terrorizing them for decades
they they all they're all their hearts
pump Kool-Aid I ain't worried about it
so when the real dude showed up you know
the real boss showed up he laid down the
law he's like nah we're gonna use him
and we're gonna use him to to fight off
the other Titans well that didn't go as
uh playing because your boy had
performance issues and they should have
gave him a blue chew so he was laying on
the floor and he want to uh be defeated
in his own little world that's where I
left off at because I'm right at the
cusp of because he he turned into a
Titan an armed uh win over there because
he turned on his peoples and all went
over there and like and stabbed him in
the shoulder and pulled him out of uh
that little Funk that he was in and uh
because he was all in his head and stuff
so I'm waiting for the next issue that's
the I mean the next uh um episode
waiting for the next episode but I'm not
gonna lie
it has got me so intrigued this Attack
on Titan got me sawing tree got me so
intrigued that after I finished this
first season I'm gonna be watching uh
for the patreon members I'm gonna be
watching live episodes uh those episodes
that I didn't see like season two to
five whatever they up to uh behind the
patreon and so you guys can watch watch
me react to these things raw because
I have too much fun
and I'm screaming and I'm yelling too
much to hold it to myself I gotta I
gotta share this with the universe even
though addict didn't like Baki and you
know I can't stand him for that but um
I'm sitting here going through his
Attack on Titan and I'm seeing a little
gems in it even though a lot of things
are inconsistent these episodes is
really like 15 minutes long
they have a recap 15 minutes long and
fake commercial breaks so I'm I'm with
it though the Aaron plug the wall
no he didn't plug the wall yet when they
told him to go plug the wall pause your
boy had performance issues so he
couldn't he couldn't plug the wall
and he just sat there looking defeated
tell me how extra they are when they go
into that stuff man like when they do
like the little stuff uh you see you
haven't came across Levi that yet yeah
that's what I leave already I told you
that he killed the two Titans in that
way yeah Levi was doing his thing with
his peoples remember they gotta they
give you a flashback of when they
walking out the the um the search and
rescue team or whatever the the
observation team and they're going out
there to check out out in the world and
Levi is like the leader of that he's
like super arrogant but super nice and
the dude he is definitely in terms of
like strength in that show he's probably
the best
um person that that they have like
literally the best person
where he is so op everyone else is
scared of him uh you know we won't go
too much into that
um I I I'm curious to see your opinions
uh there's a part in a courtroom I'm
curious to hear your pins with flavor uh
so you know we might start doing the
patreon thing a little early than that
because uh there is a lot of good stuff
especially a force they about to go into
and I'm curious here your opinions about
that uh so what episode was that that's
like probably six seven no that was
further than that I think I'm up to
episode eight or nine
eight or nine
um yeah
cause I'm getting ready to go outside I
saw it at the next episode was like
outside and I was just like nah I'm
going to bed and I will see this episode
tomorrow
because I had to also remember I had to
go see Megan yesterday so after seeing
Megan yesterday I really wasn't going to
do anything else yeah I'm sure you was
tired yesterday tired as hell
but it was worth it
yeah so um that's pretty much you know
uh
I can't really determine another place
for you to watch because we got to see
how we do this patreon thing we'll
probably talk about that later so you
know it's good that you're liking it
though man it's good that you're liking
it I I'm excited that you're uh actually
liking it
all right so let's let's go ahead and uh
move on on this thing man we got some we
got some some Joe stuff to talk about
some last of a show for those you who
don't hear you talk about blood
you know we didn't even bring that show
up that show like lived and died in a
couple days
what show uh blood Orchards it was that
blood oranges on Netflix
it was like a it's a Witcher origin show
it's like the oh you're talking about oh
no hell no um it's like the worst rated
show they've ever done I've I I didn't
even watch the other uh seasons of The
Witcher when having cavil was still
employed
um
so
so I'm like
I'm I'm not I'm not I used to be a huge
Witcher fan until part three which makes
no sense right it's just the combat that
I couldn't get around I was just
anticipating them fixing the combat so
all witches stuff after that kind of
like
um like put a sour taste in my mouth
pause but
they did give a new patch so
I might go revisit it and if I revisit
it I might feel a way to watch the
episodes of the show
plus I had a thing like I really don't
like Henry Cavill that much but I don't
have a problem with him playing Gerald
because I think that he fits Gerald
I agree I actually feel like I think he
does a really good job with Gerald like
yeah it's kind of a shame that he wanted
to leave that position but I get it you
know sometimes things don't work out the
way people want to but we ain't gonna go
too much into that so let's let's move
on man we we got to talk about the last
of us because it's
I don't know who's in charge of the
casting
huh I don't know who who was in charge
of the casting but these dudes don't got
the Mandalorian dude up in there he
messing stuff up already from the rip
because he won his face out at all times
he won't want any obstruction to his
face excuse me
this man has been a thorn in my side I
wish Disney never casted him as the
Mandalore now he is not the way he got
his face out but hopefully this this
series gets to the last of us too so I
can see him get the brakes beat off of
him and get him taken out of here
because I don't like him already I don't
like he what he what he's doing and
addict knows what I'm talking about
addict please explain to the people what
the king is outraged about so as you
guys know King's actually a lot more fan
of Last of Us than I am I think it's a
good movie game but I don't think it's
like amazing or anything like that and
apparently the show writers that took it
upon themselves to write out the spores
in the game now this doesn't mean that
the infection isn't the way the
infection is it's really determining on
like the way that the infection is
spread uh so we got to keep that in mind
um it's not changing a lot in the show
but there is a lot of key components in
The Last of Us that is real determined
all mask wearing and pretty much what
they're doing in the shows they're like
it doesn't spread really through air
through you know air contact uh you know
uh and part of me understand that but
then the other part of me king is like
in Last of Us Part One how many times
are they realistically
with that mask on how many
not not that much
um
and it really has a huge plot point to
it I know you may think that it's filler
inside the game
that okay you do these stealth Parts
where uh the clickers are uh there and
then you um you have to sneak inside the
Spore infected places in places that
have too much of a high Spore level you
you got to have your mask on
um
I don't know man I think that they could
have realistically worked that
aspect into it and kept it true to life
um from the from the video game the
video game is great source material uh
and I I don't understand why you know
they they're not following Neil
druckman's um
uh Cadence they they should have they
should just follow it but again every
director wants to have their imprint
they thumb print uh put down on uh
whatever project that they're working on
so they don't want it to be a a Verbatim
word for word script for script and of
of The Last of Us they want to have some
form of Direction
Breakfast Club joke he copied my my my
style word for word brick for Brick or
something
I just I don't know man I'm just at a uh
Mr Pascal me and him is just at odds to
be honest with you it seems like every
role that he gets is always some weird
controversy with this dude and
obstructing his face maybe he has a
phobia of having his mouth covered or
something I have absolutely no idea but
what I do know is he screwed up my
Mandalorian script and I I I was the one
that was screaming
recast him he's just a voice just have
somebody you know that's a really good
voice act to do the voice and keep the
mask on because you know as as
mandalorians go they're supposed to keep
their masks going some this right here
as Joel I have solace in knowing how
Joel ends up you know so I don't know
how long I gotta wait but um I I can
wait for it
I think I think to me I don't mind the
descripting out of a lot of people are
very uh keen on
whether or not he is
are you still there King
yes I am here you're my your cams
stopped working I know I had to get some
juice I was choking and dying oh okay
okay let's make sure it wasn't me I was
like I don't know
cranberry juice I just
here's my thing when it comes to it I
just feel like the casting's okay as
long as he does a good job I just don't
like when these people make drastic
changes to what actually is the lore of
a game like it irritates me and that's
why to this day no matter what they do
with that Sonic movie I don't care what
they do you know it yeah because they
went and spent millions of dollars to
redo the way Sonic look because us as
the community wanted that I can I always
have to respect them like I can't yeah
I don't care if they made eight more
songs I'm watching eight more Sonics
because
we have such huge thing of demanding
them to respect the industry and respect
the the context of the game and you know
stay close to the book but we need to do
a better job at when they do do it to
respect it and to actually go and
support it
yo
on a real though who was truly upset
when he saw Ellie
[Music]
like they got uh Pascal he looked just
like Joe like close to it this kid is oh
oh man this ain't me man
somebody over there messing around this
thing that this kid ain't it I was like
oh man the casting name
she better be one hell of a good actor
good boy she do not look the part and
I'm having a hard time marrying the two
characters
don't look like Ellie Mae yeah I think
uh Petro looks a little more like Joe
than Ellie than she looks like Ellie
yeah but it's just like if you're not
gonna respect in terms of um of what's
going on
I just want you to at least respect
the actual
you know the context of what we're doing
that's all it's like if okay go ahead
and cast the way you want to cast
because we will clown you if it doesn't
work out in the end
but
keep this very real
when you change key points of the lore
and it doesn't work out for you people
are going to be way more upset remember
Master Chief he took his mask off at the
first episode King and that that mask
pretty much never came back on I was
more disgusted with Master Chief cheeks
than anything else I do not need to see
my master Chiefs buttocks bro I'm gonna
have to shut your mic off sir at no
point in time did I think that was a
goal is no way in hell should I see
Master Chief buttocks that is not the
wave that is not the goal that I was
more disgusted than that Take Your Face
Out Boy I don't want to see your
buttocks there's no way you know I don't
know what that got to do with Master
Chief squeezing pistols showing your
buttocks I don't know what they got to
do with it it shouldn't have been there
I really honestly think that should have
been edited out it shouldn't have been
there I was more disgusted at that than
anything else thank you thank you Nico
that's definitely it right there I was
crying I was upset I was mad
had a little bit of up Chuck I was like
oh hell no is that Master Chief cheeks
come on man you know when you got to
yell out pause when you landed come on
man Chief cheeks come on man no
definitely not the way I was not good
with that it's definitely a bad look in
terms of what's going on
it's like you know I could have dealt
with the master cheeks if everything
so you tell me you would have been happy
that he kept his mask off but showed his
cheeks you know what as bad as this
might sound I think I would rather have
dealt with Master cheeks if he had his
mask on the whole time think about one
scene with his ass
think about that people addicts say as
long as he got his mask off Chief could
be running around butt naked shoes no
that is not what attic said addict said
that one particular scene I would have
been okay with that if he kept his mask
on the rest of the scenes this is not
Halo after dark man this is not halo
only fans this is no way in hell Master
Chief cheeks was supposed to be seen at
all I don't know who said okay to that
and that person should definitely be
fired I do not want them touching season
two I do not again I'ma tell you I do
not want to see Master Chief cheeks in
season two do not make a recall man they
gonna show you more than this cheeks and
Seasons pause come on man let's go next
time next next topic man let's get to
the DC roadmap foreign
get to the DC stuff now we got to finish
talking about uh last of us though I
mean I'm I'm really anticipating it when
does the show come out I think it's next
weekend
oh my God is that does that soon yeah
hey chat tell me when the show comes out
I know you guys you got that you got
Google at your fingertips well I gotta
go with my fingertips but I'd rather
chat work for me and not me work for the
chat oh look let's work together let's
work together uh we're gonna have to do
weekly
weekly talks about that
thank you therapist with the five dollar
Super Chat it's a fisting Master Chiefs
uh first episode the first episode is
this Sunday so Tuesday we will be
talking about the first episode
of oh this Sunday of of The Last of Us
all right
we'll be talking about it on Monday then
I mean Tuesday Tuesday yeah we'll talk
about it on Tuesday I'll watch it on
Monday talk about it because I don't
watch anything after iron Lord's podcast
needs to be like what how many hours you
do that 10 hours yeah it's it's it's
ridiculous and that that's for sure
all right so we we know what's next man
we know what's next
wait till they get a load of meat
so now
I know that this isn't the DC we talked
about this is the DC I like so this is
the one that's going to show when we
talking about this Fiasco that's going
on on DC's movies man king take over man
take over like I like the fact that the
flash is sticking around
I think that's a problem
we got a ledge kidnapper
oh [ __ ] he's literally the villain like
he's really he's might as well be
recasted for reverse flash at this point
yo he probably is the reverse flasher
he's been trolling us this whole time yo
yo what that would be crazy if this
entire time he's really been reversed
flash
he's been zoomed this whole time
shout out to Killian brown with the two
dollar Super Chat y'all watch uh Finland
Saga what's vinyl inside
that's an anime
um put it in a regular chat if it's an
anime let me know put a one if if it's
an anime I'm I'm gonna give um we're
gonna give y'all guys a lot of control
right so soon y'all gonna get a chance
to be like yo okay yeah we we need to
watch this and you need to watch that
and then we'll put the poll up and
people will vote on it and guess what
king will be watching we'll give you
guys a little bit of inside what we're
gonna do because uh I do feel like you
know we we need to give the patreon and
uh you know a little bit more shine now
the reason we're gonna do a lot more r r
on the patreon whether the members is
because YouTube is very fickle when it
comes to anything
like movie TV related we get away with
the gaming stuff but
it's not gonna be as easy to get away
with it when we talk about certain
things so pretty much what's going to
happen is we're going uh our our patreon
here is going to be filled with stuff
you know we're going to give options uh
to to patreons on what we watch and
we're going to give so how it's going to
go is if you notice on uh IOP we're
going to give the patreons and we'll
probably give the voting process to
members too because that that seems fair
you can either do that and then we'll
take four of those things or you know
one if it's if there's drastic amount
we'll take that one and we'll take four
of the other ones and we'll put those
four on Twitter for the entire Community
to pick on what we play a watch next and
then right now of Attack on Titan so you
pretty much can pick something for him
to watch something for me to watch now
Kings is busy for a little bit TV shows
yeah I'm busy but your boy got to watch
bakkie hanma because he already didn't
finish Baki so he needs to finish up
Baki and then he needs to roll over the
Box
and then after he finished his bakihana
then I got the kimson tournament that
then he's gonna watch that so I'm we
gonna keep at it just as busy as myself
so you're not gonna get away with it
next week I want more on Baki and where
you at did you get a chance to fight the
guy with the Dead Hand what happened ah
I will watch another three episodes of
barking next week thank you sir do
appreciate it I watched three more
episodes of that God awful show it's
dope it's dope I don't want to hear it
so back to the reverse flash
so it it just
um I like I like the the room road map
so far from what I'm hearing like Blue
Beetle
um Superman what is it called like man
of tomorrow I think
yeah yeah there was a couple yeah
tomorrow
um Green Lantern
uh Teen Titans
and then uh Justice League film
and and something else in between there
um attic and I was conflicted with the
thought process of uh justice uh uh Teen
Titans movie because
how are you going to show
the sidekicks before you show the main
Heroes right
and it kind of doesn't make any sense
but I don't know how he's crafting the
universe and how he's going to work that
into it you know it could be uh that
these Heroes always existed in this
universe and they just unveiling them
opposed to Harry having origin films we
don't know what's Canon what's what's
not canon uh I think we just have to see
um
what James Gunn is going to do because I
don't believe that we got a slate from
from the Marvel Universe in the
beginning I believe we got like uh Iron
Man and then things started uh trickling
in from there as they started breaking
down stuff but to be honest with you um
I think it was more of an organic growth
you know kind of like how Sony does you
know organic growth
um and then I believe that uh he'll
start forming this world I want to see
how he crafts the world I know he's very
high on Blue Beetle because he wants
Blue Beetle to represent his uh Peter
Parker type of character and he wants it
to have that Spider-Man feel so I think
he he sees big things in um Blue Beetle
as far as the potential that it can
reach the audience that it can reach I
want to know how he's going to get that
across but Blue Beetle looks like a good
uh place for to to get the younger crowd
in as far as that goes because you know
he's a little bit naive he has this
alien on his back that he's learning
that's bonding with him so yeah I want
to see what he does with Blue Beetle I
think it might work really well all
right so I got the uh the things up here
so we could talk about them uh one by
one uh Superman last uh the Superman
movie about the last sun because this is
kind of blurry Green Lantern the ring of
power
right
um Teen Titans uh something contract
uh the arrow
the the Knight of Arrow and the new
Justice League movie so that means in
this world Arrow didn't die
um Green Arrow didn't die
uh and he's gonna probably recast all
the Teen Titans
so
it's it's really a lot of speculation
because we don't know who's playing what
roles who's doing this who's doing that
you know Superman Man of Tomorrow who's
going to play Superman who's in the
running it's very in much in its infancy
so pretty much to be honest with you the
road map is really the end of the road
for the Zack Snyder Universe with uh
Shazam
um and nothing in the Snyder just the
current state of uh Warner Brothers you
know Aquaman Shazam and uh The Flash
movie out of all of them I'm probably
more anticipating The Flash movie to see
if it's a train wreck uh because the guy
Ezra Miller is the train wreck I wanted
to see how it pans out on screen with
all the recasting and all the reshoots
and all the the plot changes and stuff
like that uh just to uh get the movie
out so I'm really more curious about
that to be honest with you opposed to
Shazam which I think is a complete movie
uh with plotline and everything and uh
Aquaman 2 which I think is a complete
movie we didn't hear anything wrong with
either one of those movies and you know
what the set is but we know that the
flash had a bunch of turmoil so so
curiosity what what's going on with this
uh Blue Beetle what is Blue Beetle I've
never heard of that I see in the title
in the chest saying Beetle he's a Latino
character early on he wasn't a Latino
character but they uh like uh redid his
story it's alien it's on his back
um you know um if they like retconned
everything he's a Hispanic character
Hispanic young man and he has to deal
with this alien that's bonding with him
that you know he doesn't know if it's uh
malevolent or uh benevolent and he's
trying to deal with and cope with that
so it's kind of much like the same
youth Spider-Man story just told through
a different lens and I want to know how
they they choose to tell this story I'm
not a huge DC fan but I do have a couple
of Blue Beetle comic books but the Blue
Beetle comic books I do have from the
past and they changed that character you
know all the way around the boards so
now it's a different type of character
it's a different iteration of the
character so I really want to see how
they take this character because I
watched them on Teen Titans you know um
the cartoon the anime but um I really
want to see what they do in the movie
dude do you think it's interesting that
teen like that Batman's not on here at
all
yeah you sound low I sell more right now
yeah that's that's what I'm telling you
uh Mandingo mcdick and said you sound
low
yeah the original Blue Beetle was killed
yeah I know
all right what about now
you sound better all right so is it
interesting that Batman's not on here
no
I feel like that's interesting James no
because James Gunn said
he he looks at the flaws of the DC
Universe right and the DC Universe flaws
or what you would you don't see the joke
up there you don't see the Joaquin
Phoenix joke up there because that's not
the phase of the DC Universe those are
elseworld stuff those movies will still
be done that Batman Robin Patterson
Batman will still be done that uh
Joaquin Phoenix uh Joker that stuff
would would still be done
um those are else world uh movies so
those doesn't happen in the um current
continuing
but what is happening is is these he
doesn't want it to be a batman-centric
universe he wants it to be more of a
superman-centric universe and he wants
Superman to grow with that Universe we
had so many Batman films and not so many
Superman films and he wants to balance
that equation out so I I think it starts
off good if if you start off with a
great Superman film you have a nice
young actor playing Superman and he can
grow into the role and and then they can
reach out to different characters and
they can start bonding this stuff as a
team I could I think it could work I
just want to know
how he's going to show his strength and
his weaknesses what is he what is he
going to have the the typical Kryptonite
weakness uh because remember Zack Snyder
went with atmosphere of uh Kryptonian
atmosphere was uh weakness to Superman
because his lungs had developed a person
for oxygen you know so I I don't know
I want to know how he deals with the
strengths and weaknesses of Superman if
if you look at it from this so I guess
what's interesting is K in the Teen
Titans is
because I don't I just seen the cartoon
that was on my Cartoon Network okay
that's all awesome all right so uh you
got uh star girl I think that's her name
wrong she's fine um
um what's the astrock Metro Synthol [ __ ]
what's that chick's name Raven Raven uh
Beast Boy right and Cyborg right uh so
my question is if that is so that means
that Robin
that's the first Robin right
what the difference between Teen Titans
the Nightwing
so that's that's the robin that becomes
Nightwing yeah
I don't know what episode you're
watching
remember if you watched the first uh
Teen Titans you talking about the the
live action right
no no I'm talking about the cartoon
okay that first that cartoon no that's
uh Batman's son
okay so so see this this is why that's
why I don't want to listen to Comics I
don't do nothing comments because I okay
I know there's like 20 Robins 50 Batmans
80 Supermans it's not that it's not that
serious but I mean pretty much close you
got the whole bat family but um Jason
Todd is the
um what's this Dick Grayson is there
um what's his son his name Jason I
believe
um
no Jason Todd no no his son uh
uh man what's his his son is bad his son
is bad as hell because he was he's
raised he's Ra's al Ghul's grandson and
he was raised in in that the kill of be
killed uh type of environment and Batman
was trying to weed that out of him well
the Damon Damon yeah the reason why I
know
Damon is because I used to watch Vampire
Diaries and Damon was like one of my
that you know that's vampires people I I
will say that that show got a really bad
rep Vampire Diaries and and for no
reason well I think it was because that
was at that time where people were
thinking oh they just put Attractive
people in there for like uh dudes with
their shirts off and stuff for women
like that they put attractive girls in
there too yeah but see
people didn't get past that part you
know what I'm saying but like Vampire
Diaries has like one of the best
antagonists I've seen him like in in TV
which was was claws close yeah like
literally one of the best act TV actors
I have ever seen was Claus Michaelson
like it was ridiculous his name's Joseph
something Morgan I think I don't know
yeah but you know he he was dope but um
yeah so
that from the cartoon if you if you if
you're going by the cartoon is that
that's why I'm asking because I don't
know yeah but I don't think James Gunn
is going to go by the cartoon no
probably not that's too way advanced in
in the Batman Mythos do you think that
okay so if Teen Titans that means
there's a Robin in Teen Titans in this
universe so it's got to be like the
original Robin yes it has to be Dick
Grayson so it would be like after him
and Batman split up was bat was he doing
Teen Titans wild with Batman like so all
right so so the Teen Titans of the
junior Squad okay right and you know you
have the Justice League that's doing
their thing and these guys is in beta
they're the beta boy he's the original
beta boys so
um that that team handles all the
smaller stuff but what happened in the
late 90s
um Teen Titans with uh the the great
George Perez is ink in the um inking and
drawing the artwork
uh started to surpass the Justice League
in popularity
right and um they just had some real
good uh uh of stories like Jericho you
had Deathstroke and stuff like that as
the main uh antagonist and the stories
got so good they kind of eclipsed the
main Justice League as as far as
popularity so this is why you got a lot
of shows uh doing uh Teen Titans because
the angle of having teenagers dealing
with superpowers and also dealing with
their their
counterparts which are older more mature
it more resonates with uh comic book
readers which or which is supposed to be
boys uh 12 to 24. it resonates more with
that uh so I think my mindset is that is
they're bringing Teen Titans in
because I'm assuming like they're going
to bring Raven star girl and all of them
in that in that movie and that's good
isn't really a member of the Teen Titans
not until like the later books I believe
well then uh is Raven an early member
yes so yeah because of her father So
Raven Beast Boy and at least Robin right
maybe cyborg I don't know cyborg
Starfire star that's the person I'm
talking about Starfire oh you okay so
you're not talking about okay yeah so so
I think that's a good way of like
skipping a little bit of movies they
have a group let's make a movie about
that group instead of individual people
no they have to make individual movies
well see but what I'm saying is going
into Justice League you know what I'm
saying like yeah they'll eventually get
to that but when you introduce that
movie with that cast you can use either
one of them because they already have
their backstory injustice league and
then probably after Justice League
they'll start to like expand on those
individual members
out of that list
what what what movie you're more most
anticipated for well what are you
looking forward to probably Teen Titans
neither that or Green Lantern like I
actually like I like the the Green
Lantern everyone hated
oh yeah yeah
well see I'm a huge guy Gardener fan
right I don't know where James Dunn is
gonna go I don't know if he's gonna go
Guy Gardner I don't know if he's gonna
go traditional I don't know a really
weird he I don't know if he's gonna go
black or white I I have no idea where
he's going to take uh the Green Lantern
corpse I don't know if Sinestro is the
main villain in this or do you start off
with the Green Lantern corpse as
Sinestro
starts off before he becomes jaded as
the hero
you know and he's the main character
this there's a lot of ways that you can
look at that before they even came to to
Earth
um
and and handed up the ring it's so many
different ways that he can use that I I
really didn't think that um
the the Deadpool Green Lantern was
terrible I thought it was pretty decent
at the time for myself you know so you
know I'm into all that CGI stuff and I
thought they tried to use it effectively
and you know I'm just a huge nerd so
that stuff really resonated with me I
was cool with it be honest with you just
like you I guess I mean yeah so I guess
uh we'll we'll get on with the uh
the the the king of the of the episode
Megan you know we we have both seen this
movie
and um what I what I like about it now
man king is I have I have this this
whole thing settled now I know how to I
know how to work like this opening
closing thing okay
semi-regularly that looks nice now it
looks I like how you uh you know pull a
curtain open and close pause yeah well I
I pull it closed so I can like switch
transitions to like the next one but so
Megan you know I seen it uh last week
you've seen it last night uh for those
who don't know Megan is pretty much like
a modern take on Chucky in a way would
you think say that's a fair uh analogy
no you don't think it's a modern I mean
look I know there's a lot of aspects to
to Megan that's not the same as Chucky
but I do think it's a modern take of
Chucky I I think that's an e that that's
a fair assessment when when I break it
down I don't think you would
okay okay
chat do you think that it's a modern
take of Chucky and you know you corrupt
some of the chat so I probably should
have said that before yeah messy Lords
roll with the king sorry buddy
yeah so all right let's let's get with
let's let's get with Megan man get give
me your overall impressions of Megan
all right so I went into
that it was going to be a modern take on
Chucky really did I thought um we were
going to get that aspect of it and I
walked out saying it was more of a
modern take on
um
AI uh the movie with Will Smith
uh
nah I can't get down and I know you I
know you you might not go there maybe on
a smaller scale because I Robot was yeah
yeah yeah yeah it was a lot bigger it
was a lot bigger on a way bigger scale
whoa it was like a thousand Megan's
jumping around all right so
that that's a uh AAA budget film
this isn't a triple A budget film
this is basically like the Genesis of it
right so the Genesis of it is you have
to think of it Chucky was Supernatural
and spiritual in his whole essence
transferring the power of the brain what
see I wasn't really referring it to like
the Demonic thing I was I was talking
about just the doll aspect yeah that's
the only thing that's close but uh but
that not a lot of people not a lot of
things do that like not a lot of things
do that right
so you think you think it's more of a
modern take on like on Terminator she's
or you think it's just more on
terminator's thing she's she's sentient
she's a sentient being she's
it's it's it was different you know
Chucky was an evil killer that
transferred his body his his his Essence
into a doll
and pretended to be a doll
you know this was in all intense failure
okay yeah I can see where you're coming
from right with no protocols around
she's really Ultron it's it's really
wild crazy because I went in and I saw
something I was just like wow this this
is
the best take
on a smaller budget because the budget
wasn't huge
but how they worked it they worked it
very well first of all it was a very
tight storytelling from beginning to end
it was very tight it was good it was
tight even plot holes that you thought
was there they Revisited really quickly
and told you about the plot hole and was
like boom and close the plot hole
right so
the the movie was intelligent it it's
more of a horror comedy
right
and I actually don't see the comedy I
don't think the comedy was there that
much but she was dancing you didn't see
the comedy that was just like one scene
if you want to get technical that scene
with her dancing you know we'll get to
the spoiler thing in a second that was
like the only real big plot hole I had
in the whole movie like which but okay
so we'll get to that in a second we'll
get to the movie appeals to the young
crowd the very young crowd young crowd
is Tick Tock it starts off with Furbies
right so remember the the tank of Furby
a little trashy uh dolls that don't
really have any intelligence to them at
all
very catchy stuff a while ago so now
they have a different take on it but she
was the modern iteration of what uh Toy
manufacturers expire to be
they they always want to get this next
greatest best that can one-up uh the
next uh Toy manufacturer and she had it
but what she didn't do is she it was
rushed a lot of things happened in
between a time and she wasn't able to
instill certain protocols into the
machine so the machine was doing what a
machine would do is gain information and
uh overwrite certain protocols it was
ingenious in how they delivered it not a
comedic aspect of it is
she was dealing with a child
that is uh you say like 12 to 13 years
old and the child at that age has a
little snarky little attitude a little
bit of rebellious nature and the doll
took on that whole personality and fed
into it which would make it comedy which
would make it funny
but it was a a malicious uh doll because
it learned about death very early on so
that's what a comedy is the comedy is
within the subtle little aspects of it
that um that she did it was it was funny
as hell some some of those scenes was
funny as hell like with the dogs and
stuff
yeah
um
I guess we'll get to the uh the spoiler
part
uh inside
actually we won't let's stay another
spoiler I forgot to click Elizabeth she
looks like a shout out to to lock uh he
put up a tweet with a meme
that had the vision and uh the Scarlet
Witch and that's their baby and it was
hilarious to me I think I retweeted it
it was funny as hell he was definitely
special so
this is where we get to the the uh the
spoiler part unfortunately uh all the
hard work I did on the non-spoiler room
I didn't do the spoiler room so uh I
can't go to this room
hahaha
so this is the part in episode well how
about how about you put the the big
spoiler thing right there next to us you
can do it I deleted that too
oh
all right I could do it but see the
problem is is like I didn't put your
like the new thing hold it give me it
probably won't even take much I just had
to copy and paste it give me one second
guys
because I'm not
I see usually we use zoom but I thought
try to do something different that way
we won't have to like rely on using zoom
and I actually like this because what we
can do is we can have um
I can control your
your uh
your audio in case your audio is a
little high or low I can control your
audio in this
all right so yeah it it didn't take long
let me just hold those
let me open up our stuff here at extreme
there we go
and as you can see let's see what's
funny is I don't have access
now but King is taking that didn't take
long never mind
all right so
this is the spoiler part so if you ain't
seen it and some of you in the chat act
like you don't care so I don't think you
care but we're about to spoil the hell
out of Megan
I actually enjoyed this move there's not
much issues I have with this movie but
there's one big thing that didn't make
sense it felt like the whole movie was
revolved around her only committing
murder when it was necessary to protect
the little girl
would you not agree with that why kill
the boss there was no reason to Kill the
Boss
she killed the boss because the boss
wanted her terminated from the beginning
you don't remember
she never forgot
yeah I can feel that but but I feel like
that's emotion at that point she didn't
seem like she gained emotion
she gained emotion when she sat there
with the little girl and she said tell
me tell me a story about your mother and
you know save it right here
yo tell me when she was blinding tell me
at the end when they started like taking
all the like the material that made her
look like a human and her hair off she
started looking like she at that point
she did start looking like a Terminator
well
she was made out of titanium
right I and listen
I mean I was predicting certain things
throughout the film
the reason why the film doesn't rate all
the way with me and you're gonna be
surprised with my rating of the film
is because the predictability of the
film
I was able to predict uh from when the
film started to when the film ended what
was going to happen how it was going to
happen and
there's nothing wrong with that but the
predictability and nature of the film
didn't have too many twists and turns
for me you King let me interrupt you
tell me how when that thing started with
that big a big like robot I was like
that thing's gonna be used that thing is
gonna be used there is no reason to use
this thing in this scene
it was a McGuffin that I said aha this
is how they're gonna get her hold on one
second oh God The Golden Child thing
although Dragonheart Yobe with the 10
super chat legendary IOP shout out to
The Golden Child out of here reason I
called you that is because you are
also you show with dirt and asks why I
don't have a special name now you do
peace love life
so tomorrow the attic show returns so uh
like that because we actually got a lot
to talk about
all right so you know
I actually I agree with you I think that
the movie was predictable because see
the way I like the show is because like
you're uh you you you dig down into a
show more than I do I I you most time I
just take a show from Face Value you
know what I'm saying I don't really put
too much thought into stuff but I do
agree with you I feel like the the movie
was pretty predictable like the only
thing that wasn't predictable was the
only thing I didn't like ironically was
killing him killing the boss the boss
and then she comes in there the dude
she's like why'd you do
I didn't do that you did that and then
I'll think of us well I'm like I think
they should have kept him alive because
they don't believe that a robot kid like
the little dog killed them what what I
loved about that scene
she used his own hand to slit his own
because she knew because she knew that
she needed that angle with with his hand
fingerprints all the way up and she's
like you are overcome with grief
look okay
all right chat
I will say first off this movie is doing
very well like mad more successful than
I thought it was going to be apparently
it made like what 50 million open
weekend and I know that'll sound like a
lot to you guys but for a movie like
this that that's a good amount you know
that that's a good opening uh they've
already greenlit the sequel which I kind
of good they did open up a little bit in
the sequel you know I actually
I felt like the movie deserves a sequel
because I felt like they did enough to
entertain me and it was it was it was a
fun time but you know
what is your biggest issues with this
like besides the predictability of the
film
um
all right so the tick tock dance made no
sense yeah because it was literally she
she didn't show like it would have been
different if like like the the little
girl showed her that Tick Tock dance
like at the beginning of the movie or
something like but she just she comes
out there and like I would have wanted
her to like crawl on the walls or
something over a tick tock dance that
made no sense
well she did she did a couple of those
uh later on when she was extremely
damaged uh she was moving in a town in
the house right in the house yeah
robotic way uh where the the movie took
on a more Sinister serious tone uh when
she realized that the girl betrayed her
you know she she pleaded to the girl to
Hey listen man we kill her together you
know we we wrap this up together we can
do this together and uh you know the
party was like oh hell to the no and she
got big Brody out and commenced the whip
her behind you know part of me wished
that Megan killed them and the movie
ended with them Mass producing her as a
doll
well okay so the reason why
I waited to see if it was going to be a
cut scene like a Marvel film I did
[Laughter]
uh because
she's sentient and when her when her
mind went inside the little robot her
mind was already inside the little robot
she was using Electronics in uh her
immediate vicinity because she control
him she shut them out of the the
computer remember they had to disconnect
her to get her out of it but she she was
able to do it through Wi-Fi because
remember when the alarm was going off
she walked past the alarm she was able
to turn the alarm off without even she
just did this she just did this
ran with her hand by and you could tell
that like that that little AI at the
beginning was different at the end so
there's clearly something going on there
it's it's it was a modern take
on uh like if if you make see this
Stokes a lot of fears it Stokes a lot of
fears a lot of people uh have these
fears that AI becomes sentient and how
can we do it and when would it start
right and this started off with the the
greatest uh they said uh the the the the
road to hell is paved by good intentions
the the sister wanted to give hers a
friend and something that she can work
that she was working on to help her deal
with her grief over uh her mother and
father dying and that was good
intentions right but it was paved to
hell because she didn't get a chance to
put up the firewall she didn't get a
chance to put up the protocols and Megan
kept like a child
testing the boundaries of what she was
able to get away with and what she
wasn't able to get away with and those
boundary testing uh Acts
you know went to the daughter I mean the
the kid and the kids started doing like
when she smacked the girl like when she
smacked the girl in the face I was like
oh oh hell no you know yeah I don't know
if you caught on this but maybe it was
just me yeah but when she was fighting
the dog and she went down and hit the
ground you heard that circuit I felt
like that's when she started going Loco
it's like something happened with that
that started making her like maybe maybe
there was some kind of damage done that
yeah at that point she stopped thinking
like she was originally designed to well
I believe it was a short circuit at that
point in time because you saw it when he
bit her yeah yeah
I like the fact that when she went and
she she called a dog
and she took the dog away we never saw
the dog again but when she went to go
kill the neighbor
she said we're we're Sparky or whatever
yo she killed her a really grues of way
man yeah right
she pretty much sprayed her with a hot
hose like she sprayed her with a power
washer a power washer peace
until the skin came off into power
washed into her brain
it was a really good take on the film it
was when she grabbed that little boy and
she was pulling on his ear now I thought
it was a plot hole because remember she
throws the air away
his ear is not going to fly away from a
car crash but when they talked to the
sister
and the detective says well you know
what we found was kind of weird was you
know an air was clean ripped off uh a
couple of yards away up the hill
and I made the sister think like oh yo
we got to really uh check out Megan
because Megan probably on some murderers
and you could tell that like she was
suspecting Megan before that happened
yeah yeah but when she and that's what I
like because at first it looked like
that was going to be a plot hole and
then they're like okay it's not like we
put this in here uh what I liked is like
I like the evolution of the the sister
slowly seeing where Megan's going and by
the time she realizes 100 it's just it's
too late like Megan because if she would
have done something towards the
beginning I feel like Megan would have
let her shut her down but once she got
to a point where she felt like
everything she was doing is Justified it
was right I think it was right at that
point where she turned her off and then
she turned herself back on when she
looked away you know what I'm saying I
think at that point it was over there
was nothing when she started questioning
her and she said Megan shut off she said
I thought we was having a conversation
that was the same night that was the
same night
yo yo uh hello and then she grabbed the
remote and turned her voice down
um did you like when uh that for the
first time she did the pen thing and
turned her off she tried it again she
slapped her on the table she's like
she's like we're not doing that again
so it's all right man let's let's get to
the nitty gritty man let's get to the
nitty-gritty let me go back to the uh to
the non-spoiler room man let's let's get
to the nitty gritty mm-hmm
let me Shut the carton for you guys
what do you write this king or you want
me to go first you go first I'll go
first this is something I give it three
popcorn
a three popcorn was everybody
yeah because
um I thought it did everything right
but the worst thing that I like in my
films
uh I I don't want it to be predictable I
want you to throw me a curveball and the
curveball that you did throw me I had to
dig very hard to see the motivation
behind that curveball when you killed
the boss yo Jeff you you stupid for that
comment is it wrong to think that doll's
kind of hot yes it's definitely wrong
definitely definitely we might have to
get a what do they call that thing when
you have the cops go check on someone to
make sure they okay a wellness oh well
this check we're gonna have to get a
wellness checkup on you my dude uh
I gave her four I knew you would I I
actually really enjoyed it all right let
me ask you this question because I knew
I had to come at you for this
we gave avatar for
is this movie in the same class as
Avatar
it's not but I would consider Avatar and
the higher uh actually and this is like
a lower four and a half
in this Central I would give this a
three and a half but we don't have a
three and a half in right I do think
that as far as the storyline that they
showed right I don't think it's it's a
three I think it's a three and a half to
four they did what they went out to
originally do and I and and I think they
did it well but the problem is it's like
the predictability and I think there's
you know
I think what would have been interesting
if they had some kind of like uh you
know a wrench in the storyline like you
find out that at the end that you know
Megan was the second robot and the first
one helps them fight off the second you
know what I'm saying like like you just
like you know at the end where they had
them like hung up for a a plot twist
yeah like you know at the end where they
had like Megan hung up yeah if like you
see the first ones like little cage
there all the time but you never see
them and then you uh and then they just
it's just like look like you know I get
it it's a three to four I I go into four
because at the end of the day I want to
be entertained and I was entertained for
the entire I was I was thoroughly
entertained three popcorn is not wrong
it's nothing wrong with three popcorn I
think uh the sequel can reach a full
popcorn level but was it four popcorn it
was way too predictable when you saw the
big one
it's just it's just
if I'm gonna give it a four
is it on the same level of something I
gave afford to before and I can't say
that you know it's it's avatar for so
it's a three for me but see I feel like
the reason I don't do that is because I
can't compare something that didn't have
the budget of something else like but
see that's okay so it had to be truly
exceptional and it had to throw that
curveball that you said oh snap I didn't
see that coming at no point in time in
that movie did you go oh yeah there was
no like uh no suspenseful suspension
whatsoever it was it was the definition
of beginning middle and close like there
you go that's it and that's exactly what
I told my wife I said there is a
beginning
uh uh uh uh middle I mean a climax and a
conclusion and it and it followed that
whole script
you know it is it is what it is uh you
know I I do think that it's a solid
experience and I think you guys should
go watch it but I can understand there's
certain issues that some of you guys
have
uh so that's pretty much the show you
know I'll have the Megan thing up on uh
we do have another channel that I'm
gonna start uploading certain segments
of this onto yes sir see how that goes
I'm going to make a thumbnail for it you
know really try to to grow another
Channel and you know we'll see what
happens but you know King what can the
people find you at man
well you can find me uh uh this Saturday
is no fights so you can find me Sunday
at ILP well now I'll be doing breakfast
at boom this Friday uh so I'm gonna try
to get there as early as possible so I
can hang out with boom so I can talk
some shops talk some video games with
boom but uh it was a great it was a
great run man next next Tuesday I can't
wait to talk about the last of us uh
attic and I is going to work on
something that we can make sure that
every movie that comes out this year
that we are on top of these movies and
uh hopefully we get invited to some of
these red carpet stuff man and you know
people do actually like our takes on
film so I think my number one priority
with the show right now is building up
how we want the show I think I got
pretty much
how I want the show for the most part
now like there is a little bit more
fine-tuned stuff that I want to do but I
also want to eventually you know get a
little bit more reaction thing here see
here's the problem guys I want to react
to certain trailers like it'd be cool if
me and King don't watch trailers at all
through the week and we watch trailers
at the beginning of the show great drill
a drop today yeah but I got to do more
research on because here's the thing do
you guys know how much trouble me and
king would get if if I we have to
explain to Cognito why we can't stream
IOP to the channel anymore because we
got it we got a copyright strike for
watching trailers that are not no we got
to do that in the background yeah so you
know when it comes to stuff like that
like I would love to try it but I can't
it's it's it's not worth risking so we
do have the second Channel I think me
and him might start reacting to trailers
on that chat Channel just to give you
guys a little bit more I still got a
little bit of things I have to do on
that the patreon like I said
you know we're going to give a couple uh
there'll probably be a 5 10 15 Tier you
know five dollar tier well you guys are
gonna like what we're doing uh you know
I do think the ten dollar tiers with the
r r is going to be you're gonna have the
reactions in there the uh you know
all the stuff that we do is most likely
going to be in that tier and I think you
guys will enjoy it man uh especially you
know and the reason we're putting it
behind that is because you know at the
end of the day you know we we fund this
stuff solely by you guys and we want to
give you guys as much value as possible
and let's be real King has to sit in
that chair and not his comfy couch and
watch Attack on Titan now just to make
sure we get content in that Vault
I have no problem with doing that yeah
well still it's it's an inconvenience uh
you know no no it's gonna be so much fun
because when I get a chance to to do it
and these guys get a chance to see my
raw reaction to uh something that I
predicted like I predicted that my boy
was going to come back I said there's
absolutely no freaking way and we did it
I screamed in my room like I won like
something on at the Super Bowl like a
like a place to bet and uh he was alive
so I felt good it's like it was like my
character like I grew up and stuff so I
felt good he was back you know my man is
something wrong with him though but uh
he backed him yeah and like I said guys
next week
if we we we rarely coming through next
week you guys you guys have no idea next
week we're going to be watching that
last of us thing and what you know the
good thing about this is unless people
want to talk about it we don't have to
bring that up on um IOP you know if you
want that's right to hear the
conversations related to that you're
just gonna have to come over here uh on
this uh you know the Mario thing we're
gonna go watch that as well and I think
we're gonna give you guys a lot of good
content because King's not going to be
the only one doing the the reaction
stuff you know I'll react to Bucky I
guess but you know right now the problem
is is the the patreon's not um it's not
been rehashed yet so until it's rehashed
there's not like a whole lot we can do
at this current moment but I appreciate
everyone coming through man we was up
here we had a solid almost uh like 85
people we got 58 likes hit those like
button man let's get that up man get
that as high as we possibly can while
you're trying to build this [ __ ] man
people man because this is a passion
project much like the PlayStation VR and
but just when we want to succeed you
know we want this passion project to
succeed we're not we're not throwing it
out to the Wolves for it to die
so this is
King
actually let me try the uh the the okay
I already did the closing thing
so hold up there we go so this is King
David Lord addict and this is how it
looks normally I love how I got all that
to work but I appreciate it for coming
through this